Salut... *rire*
Aujourd'hui on va faire une expérience exceptionnelle  tous ensemble.
Vous vous demandez sûrement pourquoi notre paravent Bouddha se retrouve dans cette situation.
Il se le demande aussi.
'fin la moitié de son visage se le demande aussi. *rire*
On a mesuré cette planche avec les controlleurs de l'HTC Vive..
Pour que dans le jeu y'est une planche en bois qui fasse exactement les mêmes dimensions
Bon on aurait préférer qu'ce soit aussi dans le jeu un paravent Bouddha mais non
La particularité de cette planche en bois, elle sera a 160m de haut au dessus du vide
Et on va devoir marcher dessus sans tomber
Moi j'ai des p'tits problèmes pas de vertige mais la peur du vide
C'est pas pareil hein !
Voila. C'est une anecdote
On enfile tous ça et on va voir s'il y'a un truc de ouf ou pas
Ça s'trouve c'est trop d'la merde cette vidéo est nulle a chier
*Cri*
Voila ça peut jamais bien s'passer il y a toujours un pète, c'est ouf *rire*
J'ai eu qu'ils allaient en sortir un sans-fil
*Chuchotement* Il étais pas trop tôt
Ok on apparait donc dans une ville qui s'apparente a être quelque chose euuuh en constuction
J'dirais un p'tit New York fictif hein ? Un petit New York fictif
"Richie's Plank Experience" c'est l'nom du jeu y a un putain d'accenceur
Ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va rentrer dans l'ascenseur sans tomber à cause du cable
On va passer de l'autre coté du capteur du coup
Parce que ce jeux est vraiment bien fait achetez le hein !
PLANK !
C'est parti
fin l'ascenseur quand il y a un trou a entre les deux portes mec
Je te jure que je rentre pas
OK on y est
On y est
Ça, c'est le paravent Bouddha
Donc
Ah mec ça fous un peut le... vertige j'vais pas t'mentir
Ah en plus ils ont bien fait en sorte qu'il y ai des éléments qui pendent comme ça
Pour te foutre les... hein ?
les jetons
On est parés ?
Attend déjà y a un blème elle est...
... Elle est pas au meme endroit que dans le jeux
Ok c'est parti !
*rire* Ça ...
... Ça grince de ouf ça rend la scène tellement comique
Bah voila !
Bah ouai c'est bien
franchement c'est cool mais enfaite
Je suis tellement habitué à la réalité virtuelle que ...
... Tu vois je peux je peux danser quoi
Je vais pas faire semblant d'avoir peur, c'est ridicule
j'avoue je fais le mec mais au bout d'un moment ça m'fout un peu le le vertige
Je pense qu'il faudrait un ...
... Un truc qu'est le long de tes jambes et qui capte les mouvement de tes jambes
Comme ça tu ...
OOOOOH
(Insultes)
T'as voulu me tuer
D'où ... d' où t'as voulu me tuer ?
D'où t'as voulu me tuer la !
Bon bref
J'ai une idée
Nous on va aller plus loin que de marcher sur cette planche
Tu vas kiffer
Quand j'étais petit j'allais souvent au cirque
Aujourd'hui
On va s’entraîner comme les mecs du cirque d'hiver
Tu sens ... tu sens la catastrophe arriver ou pas ?
Ça va être la catastrophe là
AAAH ! *cri`*
Combien sur 20 ?
18 ? Oh putain, attend j' fais mieux, j'fais mieux
Je vais me suspendre à cette planche
Et je vais partir en roulade
Tu sais y a des vidéos comme ça qui vont
bah sur les toits d'immeubles comme ça la qui se mettent en équilibre sur le rebord
Bah mec j'vais faire parti de ces gens la
Allez .... Allez
la gymnastique est en moi
J'la sens
Mes souvenirs remontent Clément
OOOH
OOOOH J'Y ARRIVE !
(rires)
Clément !
C'est incroyable !
J'suis en équilibre au dessus ... !
Attention !
Okay c'était l'expérience de la plencha j'espère que ça vous a fait kiffer
Même si y'avait pas le saucisson ni le fromage...
La plancha
Tu bois un verre, y'as une plancha
La charcuterie et le fromage...
A plus
Et la vous vous dites que c'est fini et que vous avez ri ou pas
Vous apprêtez a mettre un pouce vert
Mais attendez regardez jusqu’à la fin
Comme on pouvait le voir y'a plusieurs étages . Y'a le Fire Deck
Ou en gros je crois qu'on va être pompier
Ok voila une mission
Attends pourquoi j'ai... c'est quoi ça ?
OH
J'croyais que c’était une grenade mec *rire*
Je me suis dit putain les pompiers, ils y vont fort maintenant
Les feux apparaissent partout dans la ville
Trouve-les, éteins-les
Mais y'a pas de feu . Tu vois des feux toi ?
Y'a pas d'feu
Y'a même pas
Y'a même pas de feux tricolores d’ailleurs
C'est pour te dire
Oh laisse c'est trop cool
Alors ça c'est cool
Je vole !
Regarde moi ça mec
Y'a un feux là bas !
P'tain j'vais faire l'atterrissage
Oh non, au montage !
Ou bien je met un fist pour l'atterrissage !
AAAAH ! *cri*
Oh putain ça m'a fait bizarre
J'ai cru que j'allais mourir
Vite
C'est un peu nul
C'est un peu nul comme super hero
Je suis aquaboulevard
Et j'parle pas d'la piscine pleine de microbes à Paris
Mission réussie Clément
On est les meilleurs
Oh des oiseaux
Attention !
Ça dégage la mouette
il faut les nettoyer hein
Ah bah faut prendre soin des pigeons
Ça fait la beauté de Paris finalement
Oh l'hélicoptère de police mec
Je le rattrape pas
Oh j'suis nul
J'suis pas un vrai super hero
Mec tu sais quoi ? J'vais faire comme les vrai supers heros ils font
Quand ils sont un peut stylés
Ils vont se poser sur les toits
Ils trouvent le toit le plus haut comme ça, c'est celui là la
Ils se posent dessus comme ça
MERDE
What the fuck ?
Clément je vais me poser sur cette grue
Comme si j'étais quelqu'un de très stylé
Et je vais admirer un peu le monde qui m’entoure
Et vous demander
D'aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu
Et de vous abonner
Si ça vous a...
...Vraiment plu
A très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Tchao tout l'monde
PEACE
Fin
On va au self ou à la boulangerie ?